진짜 정말 예쁘신데요?
선생님! 선생님이 뭐 하시는 거예요?
전혀 사회적 주의가 있는 사람이 있더라도
오 눈동자가 엄청 깜하세요
까매요?
네 엄청 깜...
나 너무 무서워요
니뉴 님이 웜콜 많이 안 타시는 거 같아요
그러니까 다 예쁜데요?
하나만 골라야...
안녕하십니까
오늘 목요일
해피 터스트 데이를 시작하도록 하겠습니다
퍼스널 컬러에 대해서
저는 정말 아예 백지 상태거든요.
아무것도 모르는 상태인데
슈카님과 니네도 알고 계세요?
뭐 일반적으로 뭐 다 어울린다 이런 말을 많이 들었어요.
아 죄송해요.
퍼스널 컬러에 대해서
한번 간단하게 소개부터 좀 부탁드리겠습니다.
퍼스널 컬러가 뭐냐면요.
어울리는 색깔을 찾아주는 거예요.
그 진단 기준이
우리가 가지고 있는 눈동자나 피부색이나 머리색이 다 달라요.
이걸 토대로 각자에게 잘 어울리는 색을 찾아주는 게 퍼스널 컬러입니다.
색깔이 얼마나 중요한지 보여지는 짤인데요.
노란 피부이신 것 같아요.
피부는 좀 노란 편이신 것 같은데
첫 번째 이렇게 노란색 옷에 초록색깔 머리를 하니까
전반적으로 같이 노래지는 느낌이 좀 있어요.
따뜻한 색깔보다는 차가운 색으로 눌러주는 게 훨씬 예쁘다.
이런 예시로 보여드리는 거거든요.
차가운 색깔로 눌러주는 게 예쁘다.
근데 색깔 너무 중요하지 않아요?
밝기도 중요해요. 밝기.
우리가 왜 밝은 색깔이 다 화사해 보일 거라고 생각하잖아요.
근데 어떤 분들은
어두운 색으로
그림자를 줘야지만 예쁜 사람들도 있어요.
그래요?
네.
이게 혹시 뭐 얼굴에 의존 되어 있는 건 아닙니까?
혹시?
어...
그거... 그거는 아니긴 한데
네. 밝기가 정말 중요해요.
이분은 지금 왼쪽이 밝은 거잖아요.
네. 맞아요.
오른쪽은 어두운 거.
이제 이렇게 어울리는 색깔들을 크게 네 가지 타입으로 나눌 거예요.
봄 타입, 여름 타입, 가을 타입, 겨울 타입으로 나눌 건데요.
제가 연예인 분들 이미지로 좀 설명을 해드릴게요.
봄 타입은 유나 님.
좀 사랑스러운 이미지의 사람들이고요.
여름은 좀 청순한 이미지의 사람이 많아요.
그래서 손예진 씨가 대표적인 여름 쿨톤의 대명사고
한예슬 님, 가을 타입이시고
겨울은 카리나 님.
이런 색깔이 잘 어울리면 이런 분들은 이제 여름 쿨톤 당첨이에요.
아, 이게 여름 쿨톤이에요?
네. 여름 쿨톤 색이에요.
이렇게?
이렇게 해서?
아, 네. 맞아요.
열방태운이 있냐?
이게 지금 여름이에요?
잘 어울리시는 것 같아요.
저 핑크 어울린다는 얘기 좀 들었어요. 핑크.
제가 좀 와닿기 쉽게 남자분들로 예시를 또 정리를 해왔어요.
여기 보시면 박보검 님이 봄 타입이시고요.
왜 얼굴의 차이 안 나요?
색깔 차이가 있나, 이게?
이동욱 씨가 여름, 공유 씨가 가을, 그리고 김우빈 씨가 겨울인데
제가 두 분 진단해 드릴 거잖아요.
공유일지 박보검과일지 적극적으로 놀리시라고
제가 자르고 이렇게 좀 서사를 깔아온 거예요.
제가 좀 쉬운 예도 가지고 왔어요.
짜잔.
나와봐.
축하.
노란색, 오렌지색, 초파머리 색깔 같은 저런 색이 봄 핑크예요.
이게 지금 봄입니까, 봄?
네, 이제 봄 축하예요.
여름 축하.
여름 색깔 예쁘시더라고요.
그다음에 넘어가 볼게요.
가을 축하.
이런 색깔 입으신 사진이 되게 적더라고요.
이런 게 가을 색이에요.
브라운 베이스, 브라운 카키, 버건디.
그런 걸 잘 안.
이런 색.
죄송한데 좀 크게 만드셨어요.
추상 이슈가 있어가지고.
좀 본능적으로.
조금 안 어울리긴 한다고.
여름 한번 보세요, 여름.
여름이네, 여름.
예쁘네, 예쁘네.
근데 이미지가 진짜 확 다르구나.
그렇죠.
가을일 때 느낌이 어떠세요?
원래 가을은 좀 고급스럽고 지적인 컬러긴 하거든요.
저 왼쪽 모습을 보면서 저 땐 날씬했구나.
저일로 하게 됩니다.
어, 진짜요?
저 때가 언제?
저 때가.
겨울 축하입니다.
첫 번째 사진은 수박바 에디션인 것 같은데.
수박바 에디션.
색깔 꽤 괜찮은 것 같아요.
저 마지막 사진.
약간 윤호, 윤호가.
윤호, 윤호 같지 않으세요?
누구요?
윤호, 윤호가 좀 스쳤어요.
대표님 역시 프로는 보는 눈이 다르잖아.
그렇죠.
닮은 거 같네요, 그러고 보니까.
실물도 약간 윤호, 윤호가 좀 있지.
실물까지.
실물까지 있어요.
대표님.
근데 아마 방송을 많이 하셔서 어떤 컬러가 예쁘고 어떤 컬러는 별론지
좀 대강 감은 있으실 것 같아요.
제가 엊그제 웜톤이 어울린다 말을 들었습니다.
오, 누구 같아요?
도대체 누구한테요?
도대체 누구한테 들으신 거예요?
저도 들었어요, 어울린다는 말.
웜톤이 어울린다.
웜톤 아니고요.
슈카님한테 한 번 그러면 하나씩 좀 맞혀볼까요, 오늘?
안경 한 번 벗어주시고.
아이.
네, 맨 얼굴로.
모로로다.
어머, 근데 이마가 정말 예쁘신데요?
이마.
선생님.
선생님이 뭐 하시는 거예요?
사회적 지위와 체난도 좀 새겨주시고요.
추녀님, 추녀님.
저도 사회적 지위가 있는 사람이기 때문에.
잠시만요.
근데 이거 얼굴로 묶여도 돼요?
아니요, 아니요.
아니, 이미.
오늘 콘텐츠 다 나온 거 같은데.
이걸로.
근데 진짜 실제로 보면 피부가 되게 좋으세요.
원래 타고 태어난 건 잘 타고 태어나신 것 같아요.
이렇게 태어난 건.
그러니까 유전자는 괜찮다.
네, 맞아요.
맞아요.
근데 이제 후처리가 조금 잘못됐어요.
후처리가 좀 안 됐다.
후처리가 좀.
눈동자 한 번만 볼게요.
오, 눈동자가.
어때요, 눈동자?
엄청 까맣어요.
까매요?
네, 엄청 까맣죠.
선생님.
심술, 심술.
저 목을 조금 꺼내주시겠어요?
아니, 목 좀 꺼내세요.
목 좀.
제가 얼굴과 목 사이에 이거 놔야 돼가지고.
네.
감사합니다.
목을 조금 꺼내주시면.
우리 같이 어울리는 밝기를 한번 찾아보도록 할게요.
자, 밝은색.
고명도.
자, 고명도.
중명도.
중저명도.
별로야.
자, 어두운색.
저명도.
확실히 어두운색보다는 밝은색이 조금 더 잘 어울리시는 걸 볼 수
있어요.
밝은색은 이제 얼굴에 홈들을 메꿔주는 역할을 해요.
홈이 많으세요?
네.
홈이 조금 있으신데.
홈?
뭐예요, 홈?
얼굴.
눈 밑에가 좀 파였거나.
아.
이제 광대 옆에가 좀 파였거나.
약간 이렇게 조금 있는 밝은 색깔 을 댔을 때 훨씬 더 메꿔지면서
예쁜 느낌이 있고 어두운 색을 대는 순간 갑자기 이제.
아.
그러네.
우와.
그림자가 생기면서.
오, 그늘이 진다.
우리가 원색이 예쁜지, 퍼스텔톤이 예쁜지 볼게요.
페일, 저채도.
브라이트.
아이고.
빈 미드.
아이고요.
이랬잖아요.
그래서.
야, 이 찌들, 근데.
짤 한 번만 더 보여주세요.
아.
지금 딱 슈퍼님 어두운 색 되니까 들어간 주름선들 있죠?
그게 딱 기가 막히게 표현이 돼가지고
자 그러면 우리 아까 봄, 여름, 가을, 겨울 봤잖아요
어떤 타입 같으셨었어요?
여름, 여름
여름은 밝은 거
박보검 또는 우리 이동욱으로 한 번 찾아가시죠
진짜 이 언니 너무해
자 웜톤
자 그리고 웜톤
그다음에 쿨톤 초록
이렇게 안 봤나?
진짜 견디기 힘들다
야 쟤 네모네
견디기 힘들다니
그래서 우리는 봄 타입이 베스트 타입이에요
이런 색깔들이 좀 잘 어울리시네요
우리 이제 요거 한 번 볼까요?
오 스트라이프
약간 범죄자 느낌도 살짝 드는 거 같은데 지금
어디 텍사스 교도소에 있는 거 같은 느낌 드는데
저거 잘 봤어요 많이
저거 실체신 거죠?
네 실체신
누가 실제로 저렇게 만들어요
자 그럼 우리 안경 한 번
안경 한 번
안경
아마 이런 게 안 어울리실 거예요
아 이거 아니고
악덕사장 같아 악덕사장
문 닫고 나가 문 닫고
아 이거 너무 강해 세 보여요
맞아요 작은 거
또 올해 포엣코어라고 시인 스타일의 남성분들
시인같이 시인같이 느낌
약간 박정민님 같은 느낌의 포엣코어
이거는 그냥 눈침침하게
와 너는 아저씨
우리 작은 거니까 이렇게 큰 게 안 어울려요
안녕하세요 송승헌입니다
송승헌 선생님 이런 안경 스타일 많이 쓰지 않으세요?
근데 아니죠
죄송해요
여성분을 대변하는
아 저도 해야 돼요?
니뉴님도 이제
음 너무 가까이 하지 마세요
근데 니뉴님 진짜 예뻐요
예뻐요 아니 진짜 진심으로
왜냐면 얼굴이 너무 작고
진짜 이거 저 놀리는 거 아니에요 진짜 예뻐요
여기는 진심이에요 진짜
여기는 진심이에요
고명도 밝은색
중명도 어두운색
오 니뉴님 어두운색 좋아하신다고 그러셨죠
다 잘 어울려요
너무 슬기다 진짜
진짜요
근데 니뉴님도 밝은 색깔로 올라오셔야 될 거 같아요
아 이게 맞아요?
니뉴님이 세로 길이가 좀 짧은 얼굴이에요
옆으로 살짝 넓어 보일 수가 있어요
어두운색을 보면요
밑에 턱 같은 데 그림자가 확 지면서
턱이 되게 짧아져요
짧으니까 옆으로 넓어 보여요
밝은 색을 대면 세로 길이가 좀 길어지면서
얼굴이 갸름해 보여요
근데 물론 어두운색은 좀 시크한 이미지 때문에
되게 잘 소화하셨을 거예요
근데 얼굴만 기준으로 봤을 때는
밝은 색이 좀 더 잘 어울려요
자 웜톤 쿨톤 한번 볼게요
웜톤 쿨톤 웜톤 쿨톤
니뉴님 웜쿨 많이 안 타시는 거 같아요
그러니까 다 예쁜데요?
왜?
aba
선생님 아까 저 할 때는
뭔가 되게 냉철하고
분석 쪽으로 얘기해주더니
여기는
oooo
안녕
스텔보다는 그냥 오히려
조금 더 원색깔로 가시는 게 좀 더 좋으실 거 같아요
채도가 좀 들어가야 해요
우리는 가을 색깔이 잘 어울리는
가을 여자
네 가을 여자예요
약간
한예슬과
아 잠시만요
그만해주세요
한예슬이 아니잖아 이런 말을 해줘야죠
아 그래요?
슬쩍 좀 네 괜찮아요
그래서 이런 색깔들이 굉장히 잘 어울리시는 타입이시고
근데 이런 색깔들이 좀 안 어울리는 색깔
약간 좀 쨍해야 될 것 같아요
맞아요 좀 색깔이 이렇게 좀 들어와야 돼요
쨍하게 좀 들어와서
너무 예쁜데요?
레드 잘 받으시다 레드 잘 받으세요
레드예요?
네 그래서 우린 아
이거 좀 제가 좀
오만세는 말을 했나요?
슈카님은 빨간색에 어울려요? 파란색에 어울려요?
색깔이 색깔이
핑크색에 어울려요
선생님 그 가게가 어디시라고요?
아프정에도
한 시간 내에 어우
화끈하지 않지 않는단 말이야
그리고 슈카님도 축하시더라고요
자기 색깔을 알아가는 것만으로도
앞으로 옷 고를 때 완전히 줄여지잖아요
이거 어찌보면 돈 아끼는 거야
정리를 한번 해줬으면
그래서 니니는?
가을여자
약간 갈색 계열
네 맞아요
약간 머리 색도 톤 좀 다운하고
네네
안경도 좀 뿔테 같은 거 쓰셔가지고
얼굴에 좀 무게감도 좀 실어주시고
패턴도 좀 큼직한 거 입으셔도 예쁘시고
딱 김희선님 고소양님 한예슬님
아니 잠깐만
왜 이렇게 자꾸 선을 넣대
지금 고소한 걸 계속 모집하고 있어요
계속해 주세요 어디까지 가나
슈카님 슈카님
한 점이 뭐였죠?
박호시형 뭐요?
박보강 조인간
세 개 세 개
저는 약간 베이직 수트 같은 것도
되게 잘 어울리실 것 같아요
저 맨날 입어요
그 쿠팡 가다만의 베이직이잖아요
그러니까 4만 원짜리 그거
2년째 입고 있거든
뭐요?
나중에 저랑 무신사 한 번
가서 좀 골라볼까요?
근데 진짜 사장님이 한 번 잡아주셔야지
우리 방송에서도
항상 지적이고 스마트한 이미지로 가고 싶은데
항상 아무거나 이제 막 좀 주워 입으시다 보니까
색깔이 좀 안 맞아요
그거 다 우리 엄마가 사준 거예요
지금 아무거나 주워 입다니
저는 이제 핑크가 어울린다는데
어울린다 야
이런 색깔이 제일 잘 어울리실 것 같아요
이런 색깔 베이비 핑크
이거 어때요?
얘보다는
얘가 발견시가 예쁘죠
우리가 롱돌이
친구들이 밝은 친구들
저랑 슈카 님하고 비슷하네
근데 봄이고 여름
여름
왜냐면 혈색이 많아서
혈색을 좀 빼줘야 돼요
지금 보시면 우리 종훈 님 같은 경우는
완전 핑크빛이에요 피부가
핑크 종훈 핑크박
손바닥 한 번 보여주실래요?
핑크 핑크
왜 이렇게 핑크빛
저거요 슈카 님 보세요
저 분 보시면 노랗고
핑크핑크예요
약간 그 뭐지
약간 꽃돼지 색깔
꽃돼지
아 꽃돼지
그거 조금 연기하고 있네요
오늘 대표님 진짜
너무 고생 많으셨습니다
여보 이제 집에 가서 소주 한 잔 하시면
아 먹고 살기 힘들다 하시는 거
뒤빨려가지고
아까 그 니 뭐
아니 뭐
근데 대표님 대표님 가게에서는
가면은 뭐를 좀 많이 해줘요?
보통은 저희가 메이크업이랑 의상이 좀 더 메인이에요
그래서 이제
어깨가 조금 더 살았으면 좋겠는다든지
요런 것들을 조금
목선을 좀 가죠
시원하게 좀 파면 어떨지
이거 하나만 풀러봐도 돼요?
오오오
어 잠깐만
잠깐만 잠깐만 이거 맞나?
많이 차이 나
와 민호야
하하하하하